- [Narrator] Turkey is
an economic turmoil.
People are queuing for
bread, cutting back on meat,
and they're even fleeing
to other countries.
Why?
Inflation, which currently
stands at more than 21%
according to government statistics.
The US inflation rate by comparison
is that a 39 year high of 6.8%,
nearly twice as much as
a global average of 3.5%.
(Kadriye speaking Turkish)
Unlike the US, Turkey
is an emerging market.
It seen two decades of
broad economic growth
and an expanding middle class, but now,
the Lira is in free fall
as the country reckons
with President Regep Tayyip Erdogan's
unorthodox economic approach,
which is contrary to widely
accepted inflationary wisdom.
As central banks around the world respond
to a stronger than expected
pickup in inflation
and mid economic recovery
from the pandemic,
there are lessons to be
learned from Turkey's approach.
In a nutshell, to prevent
the economy from overheating,
central banks can increase
the cost of borrowing
by raising interest rates,
which curbs the rate of inflation.
And this is precisely what is happening
in most other emerging
market's central banks
to great effect.
But Turkey's central bank
has done the opposite.
Under pressure from President Erdogan,
who has invoked a religious
prohibition on usury
and his argument against
high interest rates,
the rate has been cut three
times since mid-September,
which has torpedoed the value of the Lira.
A rapidly weaken currency
pushes up the cost
of key imports like food and energy.
This is already hurting the
Turkish people's bank accounts.
(Hulya speaking Turkish)
In an October survey,
more than 80% of the Turkish
public said the government
was handling the economy badly.
The crisis has prompted protests,
mostly from union members,
and calls for Erdogan's
government to resign.
(people rallying)
Turkish banks so far
have been able to withstand
the currency crisis,
but economists are concerned
that a further collapse of the Lira
could trigger a bank run,
or that Turkey could default
on its foreign debts.
Erdogan meanwhile has said
he welcomes the depreciation
of the Lira to encourage
an export based economy
similar to Japan and Taiwan.
He and other officials have insisted
that the currency
fluctuations are temporary.
Some economists have said
that the strategy is likely to fail,
because inflation has
put pressure on exporters
who now have to pay more for
energy and raw materials.
Others doubt that Turkey's
inflation is even at 21.3%.
An independent research group
estimates that in reality,
the figure is more than 58%.
Investors and economists fear
that Turkey's embattled
economy could get worse
before it gets better.